hey guys today we're ranking the eight
best one-shot spells from the first
season of black clover if you follow me
on Twitter you'll know I've recently
been catching up on this series and I
gotta say since the dungeon Ark I've
been completely hooked so in honor of my
newfound love for this show I thought
I'd do a one-shot list in much the same
way I did from my hero academia just to
reiterate though this list is from
season one specifically though there is
one spell from season two purely because
it was a direct continuation from the
season one finale I don't make the rules
people all right it's above me now also
I'd appreciate no spoilers for season 2
or 3 on the comments of this video ok so
starting at 8th place we have a spell
used by logiss he made his debut in the
finale of season 1 so this guy uses
lightning magic and despite being all
but murdered by you know the spell I'm
talking about is very capable of one
shotting multiple magic nights as we can
see him doing in this panel here during
the invasion of chiton a protective
barrier was erected around the town and
was maintained by the power of 50 magic
Knights now in the face of that logiss
used his lightning creation magic to
conjure up this spell which is way too
long for me to say in full but the point
is he creates a giant magic lightning
bow which is equipped with 6 gigantic
arrows and this was able to not only
shoot through the barrier with ease but
also decimate the ground below and like
I said take out some purple orcas in the
process I was genuinely impressed when I
first saw this belt because like how all
these magic knives like 50 magic knights
not able to stop this one man with this
one spell I mean I should probably
mention that he's one of the eight
shining generals of the diamond Kingdom
and we're told that this is the
equivalent to being a magic night
captain but with that said that makes
this moment right here all the more
tragic
moving on to seventh we have a spell so
epic that it gave me goosebumps the
first time I saw it like actual
goosebumps the sea dragons role was
first used by Noel to disarm vetto
and yeah I do mean that literally even
though she's royalty Noel has always
struggled to control her magic ever
since a young age this seeming lack of
innate skill was enough to have her
verbally abused by her family pretty
much her whole life and I cannot tell
you how much I wanted to slap this guy
now the whole underwater temple hug that
was amazing for Noel's development and
she was the only one who could actually
transport everyone to the underwater
temple and then when in the temple she
discovered for the first time that she
has an attack spell the sea dragons roar
was a one-shot spell for many
reasons I mean Vito is a member of the
third eye which by default makes him one
of these strongest characters we've ever
seen and by this point he'd effortlessly
resisted attacks from LARC magna and the
sea temple guy so the fact that Noel was
able to break through his defensive
magic rip off his arm and then crash
through the walls of the sea temple like
this was certainly a spell that could
wash off someone if used accurately
firing into sixth place we have one of
juego leon spells and i'm gonna be
upfront here guys there's a lot of bias
involved here because for girly on to me
is the coolest magic night captain there
is like period his Flame magic was on
full display during the attack on the
world capital and he used it to
incinerate several powerful puppets
being controlled by wraiths magic many
of the spells he displayed could be
classified as one-shot including this
one here which is just visually amazing
but I want to turn your attention to the
sole linear attack of which the japanese
translation literally means sun beam of
the miniature sun why is this guy so
cool this ball delivers a concentrated
beam of fire and it pierced through the
barrier of a resurrected corpse and this
was interesting because this corpse used
to be a defense magic expert and it had
been brought back from the dead and then
had its barrier in hearts by curse magic
so although for Guerlain skill was a big
factor in being able to pierce this
barrier no one could deny that being
able to break through this in any
scenario you have to be pretty
overpowered the sole linea attack was
enough to incinerate this corpse after
only making one hit and in anime we see
it used to destroy a horde of zombies in
one strike so yeah not much more to it
than that
definitely one of the best one shots we
saw this season at fifth place we have a
pretty interesting one and it has some
notable differences from the rest of
this list
so rather than instantly piercing or
dismembering the opponent in some way
this spell absorbs their magic and then
grows a tree around their body and we
saw the captain of the Golden Dawn use
this to kill one of these shining
generals of the diamond Kingdom yeah the
diamond kingdom has taken some massive
elves in this series now mistltein seed
is an awesome one-shot spell that
requires minimal effort from the user
like if we do a slow-motion replay right
here all he did was casually throw this
seed he didn't even put his back into it
and as if that wasn't enough because the
spell seemingly converts the person into
a tree in some way by using their magic
I I have to say this is probably one of
the most eco-friendly attacks we've ever
seen personally I found tree magic to be
really creative and intriguing
and I gotta give credit to the manga
curve being so creative because if you
had told me about the idea of offensive
tree magic I would have assumed that it
either be really weak or pretty
worthless not that I have anything
against trees but it's not like
something like fire or electricity where
you can clearly see how it could be
harmful but the way that William
Vengeance has used this so far from what
I've seen it's got me thinking that tree
magic is actually very very useful
moving on to fourth we have a few spells
from Licht who is clearly the
overarching antagonist of season one and
beyond Lakes possesses powerful light
magic that among other things allows him
to teleport at light speed at least I
assume this is light speed if not I'm
gonna be really disappointed when we
first probably get a look at him he uses
these darts made of light to stab a stir
in the leg and basically just destroy
this sister he was hitting everyone with
these things and I'm sure in the right
circumstances if it hit like a vital
organ this could be a one-shot spell but
I have to say that everyone I just
mentioned who got hit by these things
did survive however his finishing move
this spell was acknowledged as too fast
for Yami or asked her to evade do you
know how strong a spell has to be for
Yami to not bother to try and fight back
just think about that so in this
situation to use the spell he charged up
the light between his hands for a period
of time and then released this massive
concentrated beam of light good thing
that gauche was able to show up and
reflect it but I think we can already
notice that had he not done that both
the army and asked her would have been
disintegrated by this thing and it's
probably worth noting that he did have
another one-shot spell in season one but
we didn't actually get to see its full
capability because he was sealed away so
he couldn't really use it and so I don't
really count it on this list but I do
acknowledge that for magic night captain
seemingly believed that they would not
be able to stop it
moving into the top three the bronze
medal goes to our very special boy and
this bit of spirit magic which we first
saw used in the dungeon exploration arc
so in this moment aster was about to be
one shot hit by Mars after already
suffering a pretty serious injury anyone
who could have saved him was either
trapped inside a crystal or just unable
to do so but you know in typical you
know fashion manages to bust out of the
crystal and then out of nowhere it looks
like time is frozen this is of course
where we meet SIL for the first time and
she casually blow some air which then
shatters this massive crystal sword and
Mars his crystal armor in the process
from what I've seen spirit magic is just
like on a different
to everything else cuz to be able to
shutter this giant thing with a single
breath I can only imagine what happens
when she sneezes we see them use this
attack again during you nose battle with
this witch and while it didn't exactly
one shot hers and kill her she did have
to use up all of her magic to survive
the attack which turned up from looking
like this to looking like this so uh
overall I have no regret in saying that
this spell can do a lot of damage and is
definitely capable of being a one-shot
attack at second place we have a spell
possessed by the wizard king himself who
only showed off his powers once during
season one and I think this moment was
quite similar to when Miriah whipped the
entirety of class 1a because Julius
appears out of nowhere right and then he
instantly wastes a couple of I of the
Midnight Sun members now the wizard King
uses time magic which is clearly as epic
as it sounds and this particular spell
wasn't given a name from what I could
remember but when I watched this like I
can't remember if I laughed or gasped
probably a combination of both to be
honest because it was so absurd and just
like out of the blue because we hadn't
seen his power or magic at this point so
yeah it was really shocking moment but
pretty funny as well there's a part of
this whole scene that we didn't see in
the anime but when I read back the manga
I did actually notice when Licht appears
the manga shows us that Julius creates
another one of these time bulls which is
obviously how Licht ended up with his
disfigured arm which we did see in the
anime but we didn't see how it went down
or what spell Julius used so yeah I mean
this whatever this is called amazing
I assume the way it works is that he
liked fast forwards their lifespan until
they're like just nothing and now after
a lot of talk let's get into the best
one-shot spell in season 1 of black
clover as I'm sure you all remember
during the underwater temple arc vetto
was about to self-destruct and just blow
the place up having been thoroughly
beaten by the teamwork of the black
balls but the entire time Yami was
unavailable due to being trapped by this
spatial magic user so once he did
eventually escape he pushed past his
limits and learnt this new one shot
spell which has an amazing name so this
is the dark cloaked dimension slash and
honestly it was just absurd so this was
able to cut straight through vetto like
it sliced him right down the middle and
remember that licked even said the
members of the third eye their strength
surpasses even his own but as Yami said
it doesn't matter how strong the person
receiving this spell is because you're
getting one shotted through the
dimensions like look at the line this
left in the ground here honestly it's so
cool
I'm sure if you're this far into the
video you already know this but Yami
uses dark magic and this right here was
one of the many examples that just
validated his insane strength
on a sidenote is pretty surprising to me
that Yami is only 28 like you can't tell
me he doesn't have powerful middle-aged
energy with that said those are the
eight best one-shot spells in season 1
of black clover in my opinion there are
many others to choose from but these
ones right here stood out to me
especially let me know any that you
think might deserve a place on this list
and do let me know in the comments if
you want me to do more black clover
content I was initially planning to get
fully up to date with this series before
doing a video but I couldn't help myself
on this one so I just made it even
though I haven't finished season 2 yet
that being said in about a month's time
maybe like three or four weeks maybe I
will be doing more black level content
if you guys like it if it has a good
reception it gets a decent amount of
views if you like it and once you more
of this be sure to like catch you next
week peace